[موسيقى]
نرحب بكم اعزائنا المشاهدين في حلقه جديده
من مقابله خاصه هذه المره مع رئيس الحكومه
الليبيه المكلفه من مجلس النواب الليبي
سيد فتحي باشاغه اهلا بكم معنا دوله
الرئيس اهلا وسهلا مساء الخير اسمح لي ان
ابدا معك
بتوقعاتك للاستلام مقاليد الحكم في طرابلس
استلام مقر الحكومه في طرابلس حتى الان لم
تستطيعوا تنفيذ قرار مجلس النواب بتكليفكم
برئاسه الحكومه لماذا
اولا مساء الخير معلوم
ان حكومه تحصلت على منح الثقه من مجلس
النواب وايضا اناك رئيس وزراء وتبع هذا
الاجراء اجراء قبل يعني كان فيه اجراء من
مجلس الدوله ان المجلس الدوله زكاني ب 53
عضو وهو كما ورد في الاتفاق السياسي
الليبي اللي تم توقيعه سنه 2015
والامور كلها كانت
قانونيه وجيده ولكن الحقيقه عدم دخولنا
تمكن دخولنا طرابلس هو كان يعني
ربما يعتقد العديد من الليبيين ولا غير
الليبيين انه هو تم منعي من الحكومه
الولايه او من المجموعات المسلحه ولكن هذا
غير صحيح
الامم المتحده لم تعترف بالخطوه اللي قام
بها مجلس الدوله
والبرلمان واعترفت في البدايه كرئيس وزراء
ولكنها لم تعترف بالحكومه وشككت في
مصداقيه التصويت مع انه هو تم تسجيله
بالكامل يعني بالصوت والصوره واعتبر انا
عدم تمكن حكومتي من الدخول لطرابلس بسبب
عدم اعتراف الامم المتحده وليس بسبب من
قبل الامم المتحده هذا قوى موقف في دبيبه
صح
من ناحيه الشرعيه
لم يقويه لانه هو سحب اولا في الاتفاق
اللي تم في جنيف هي هذه الحكومه مدتها سنه
تقود ليبيا للانتخابات وتنتهي في شهر 12
واقصى مده لها كوعاء زمني بعد اجراء بعد
البدء وزراء الانتخابات هو شهر سته حتى
يتم تسليم والاستلام ما بين البرلمان
القديم والجديد وايضا
انتخاب الرئيس وانت الرئيس بانتخب رئيس
وزراء هذه كلها تحتاج الى حوالي اربعه الى
سته اشهر ولكن ايضا انتهت شرعيتها
والبرلمان سحب منا الثقه فالشرعيه الليبيه
هو يعني ما عندهاش اي شرعيه ليبيه ومنتهيه
حكومه بالكامل بالنسبه الشرعيه الليبيه
القانونيه هو اللي خلاه يستقوى وربما هو
يعني اعتراف المجتمع الدولي به
استمرار الاعتراف بها هذا فقط يعني دوله
رئيس اكيد حضرتك تتفق معي ب الوضع الداخلي
الليبي لا يحكمه فقط التوازنات الداخليه
الليبيه بل يحكمها ايضا التوازنات الدوليه
وموقف الامم المتحده موقف واضح في هذا
الاتجاه اذا ما قلنا بانه عدم الاعتراف
بكم ادى الى تاخير حتى استلامكم منصب مقر
الحكومه في طرابلس كيف ممكن تتغير هذه
التوازنات الدوليه هو طبعا لا بد لنا احنا
كان نستفيدوا من دروس
والاحداث والوقائع اللي حدثت من بعد سنه
2011 الى الان سوى نحن كمجتمع ليبي او
قيادات ليبيه وايضا كمجتمع دولي اللي تقود
فيه او كله هو تحت غطاء الامم المتحده
بالرغم ان التدخل الليبي تدخل الدولي في
ليبيا وهذا واضح للعيان واضح للناس كلهم
وهذا سبب مشكله كبيره ولكن ايضا يعني هناك
من يلقي اللوم على الليبيين وكانوا نسمع
في الكلام هذا دائما يقولون بقى انتم
توافقوا
ليش ما توافقوا هذا في الماضي يعني في
الماضي كنا نسمع فيه ليش ما توافقوا انتم
وخصماءكم الاخرين فلما توافقنا ابدى
المجتمع الدولي انزعاج من هذا التوافق
للاسف فنرجع ونقول ان المشكله الليبيه
خلينا نقولو واقعيا ان ليبيا واقعه تحت
التدخل ليبيا فيها تدخل
خارجي بعض منا سلبي والبعض منا ايجابي
وايضا هناك مشكله ليبيه ليست بالكبيره
اللي انا شفنا احنا كيف كنا نتقاتل
وانتخاصمه وبعدين لما
ذهبت الى المنطقه الشرقيه ومشيت بنغازي
والتقيت
بالسيد المشير خليفه حفتر والتقيت بالسيد
المستشار عقيله صالح ان احنا فتحنا الطريق
امام المصالحه اذا الليبيين يتقبل هناك
بعض المعارضات السياسيه لكن هذه كلها
معارضات غير حقيقيه في الواقع الليبي اذا
نرجع ونقول انه هو توافق الليبي يحتاج الى
شيئين لا
خليني من خليني نبدا الصح هو من وجهه من
نظره النظره الخارجيه ربما لما ينظر
الواحد للاعلام
التواصل الاجتماعي او القنوات يقول صح لكن
والنظره داخليه في ليبيا مش صحيحه تماما
اولا حكومه دبيبه هذه شرعيتها فقط شرعيه
المجتمع الدولي لو يرفع عليها يده المجتمع
الدولي الان حتشوفي كيف انه الناس كلها
حترحب بحكومتنا احنا هذا هذا اولا ثانيا
ثانيا بالنسبه للخلاف بين
قلتي فيه
خلافات في مصر في ليبيا المركزي وفي
خلافات بالمؤسسه العسكريه المؤسسه
العسكريه الان والحمد لله قطعه شوط كبير
جدا ولجنه خمسه زائد خمسه في تواصل ما بين
قياده الجيش والجيش في المنطقه الشرقيه
وايضا
الجيش في المنطقه الغربيه وايضا القوه
الامنيه اللي هي المجموع المسلحه وفي عده
اجتماعات عقده خارج ليبيا وايضا في تواصل
مباشر وكان في زياره شفناها احنا زياره
الفريق الناظوري ذهب الى طرابلس ونزل في
متيقه وايضا كانت في الايام الماضيه كان
في زيارات من قيادات عسكريه من المنطقه
الشرقيه الى طرابلس وفي تنسيق امنيه على
مستوى عالي جدا جدا بين سواء كانت
المجموعات المسلحه او قياده الجيش في
الغرب الليبي وقياده وقياده الجيش عبر
القياده العامه في بالنسبه لمصر في
المركزي في تعرفوا انتم في حوارات وقاطعه
شوط جيد في توحيد مؤسسه مصر في ليبيا
المركزي واعتقد ان هذه الحوارات يعني
حتنتج توحيد هذه المؤسسه بالنسبه للمؤسسات
الاخرى ايضا ديوان المحاسبه في اتصال بين
رئيسي الديوان في المنطقه الشرقيه
والغربيه والان هم على توافق وئام كامل ما
زال تنقص خطوات بسيطه جدا
وبالنسبه
للمصالحه مع النظام السابق يعني في خطوات
اتخذت مع النداء اول المصالحه بالنسبه
لفبراير لانه فبراير اختلفت مع بعضها في
الشرق والغرب والان يعني الان الان خديت
الخطوه هذه وتحملت مسؤوليتها ودفعت ثمنها
وكانت خطوه جيده والحمد لله مهدت الطريق
مش لليبيه فقط بعد الطريق حتى للامم للامم
المتحده وبعثت الامم المتحده الان اصبح
عندها سهوله في العمل وبالنسبه لبعض
الاصوات اللي رافضه هذه اصوات يعني
نعتبروها في العمل الديمقراطي ضروري ضروري
يكون في معارضه وفي لكن واقعيين
المعارضه
والدبلوماسيه والمعارضه اللي بتصفي
حساباتها على الارض هنا اعود مره اخرى معك
لموضوع المليشيات صحيح لو كنت انا مخطئه
من يمتلك
دعم اكبر من
[موسيقى]
وتحملوه لمده سنوات كثيره لكن صحيح ان في
هناك
ماخذ عليهم وما اخذ هذه يمكن لو فيه حكومه
حكومه حقيقيه او وطنيه تنظر لليبيا انه
يمكن اصلاحهم
في تعديات يعني هو مطلوب منهم ان يكونوا
ان يكونوا يعيل للدوله يعني يكونوا وايضا
ان ان
ينقصهم بعض التدريبات ولكن يبدل المستعان
بهم لانهم
موضوع الحفظ موضوع الميليشيات تحديدا في
ليبيا معظم هاي الميليشيات عندها اسلحه
ثقيله معظمها عندها اموال ايضا في كثير
منها له ارتباطات مع قوى محليه وقوه
خارجيه ايضا في كثير منها عنده ارتباط
عنده عنده ايديولوجيا معينه في التعامل مع
المسائل داخل ليبيا ايضا هناك من يعاني من
الجهويه مثل الميليشيات لها علاقه
بالمنطقه راح نتحدث عن مصر طرابلس
والزنتان والزاويه مع كل هذه الخلافات هل
هناك من لديه القدره في ليبيا على ان
يقنعهم بالتخلي عن السلاح والانضمام
لمؤسسه عسكريه في حال صار عنا مؤسسه
عسكريه موحده داخل ليبيا اولا لابد من
يكون رئيس قوي تكون امام او هدف الدوله
قيام الدوله الحقيقيه ثانيا بالنسبه
للمجموعات المسلحه والمليشيات انا اعرفها
جيدا واخبرها جيدا مستعدين
يعني ان يكونوا تحت الدوله وطاعه الدوله
على شرط فيه عمليات انتقاميه منهم هم او
محاسبه
يعني غير قانونيه
والسيء الاخر لا بد يكون في عدل وانصاف
اما اللي حصل الان انه في مجموعه في مكان
مائي اعطوها او يعطوها فلوس والمجموعه
الثانيه لا فهنا دائما يشعر هم بالظلم
ويشع الدوله ما تعاملش في معامله عادله
وبينما الدوله يعني تحتاج لهم في قتال
الارهاب بالنسبه للمجموعات المؤلزه او
الايدولوجيه هذه قليله جدا لكن انا بحسب
خبرتي لما كنت في الداخليه كل المجموعات
المسلحه
عندها استعداد لاطاعه الدوله متى كانت في
هناك حكومه واحده لكن اللي خلى الميليشيات
والمجموعات المسلحه موجوده بهذا الشكل
اللي هي سببين اول الصراع والانقسام اللي
كان والحمد لله الان في خطوات المسلحه
ثانيا اللي هي الرئيس لما
بيستخدم المال من اجل كسب ولئاتهم او
السيطره عليهم هنا تبدا مشكله كما حدث مع
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه الوطنيه عباره عن
استخدمتهم بيع وشراء
وبالنسبه ارتباطات خارجيه صحيح هناك
ارتباطات خارجيه لكن هذه مهمه الامم
المتحده والمجتمع الدولي اذا كان يبوا
استقرار لليبيا لابد ان يكون هناك توافق
بينهم وان الارتباطات الخارجيه لابد نكن
الحكومه الليبيه ويساعدوها بانها هي يعني
كل الدول تكف عن الاتصال بالميليشيات
مباشره لكن الوضع لم يستقر بعد وكل الدول
ترى ان يعني ربما تنظر انها هي تساهم في
استقرار الوضع الامني مش الكامل هذه نظره
الدول يعني لما يتصلوا بالمجموعات المسلحه
او الميليشيات الكل يريد ان يساهم في
استقرار الامل او ان يسيطر خلينا نقولوا
يسيطر على مجموعه مسلحه
دوله الرئيس ارجوك ان تبقى معي سنذهب الى
فاصل قصير نتابع بعده هذه المقابله الخاصه
مشاهدينا الكرام ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم معنا من جديد ونواصل واياكم هذه
المقابله الخاصه مع رئيس الحكومه الليبيه
المكلفه من مجلس النواب سيد فتحي باشاغه
اهلا بك معنا من جديد دوله الرئيس واسمح
لي ان ابدا من حيث توقفت يعني حضرتك
بالجزء الاول من هذه المقابله تحدثت عن
مفهوم
انا معك تفضل يا ساده منتهى انت ذكرتي
ذكرتي نقطه المصالحه مع النظام السابق بدي
ارجع لها انا صراحه بتفصيل بس انا بدي
اسالك لو سمحت بس عند ما انت انتهيت تحدثت
اكثر في اكثر من جمله عن مفهوم الدوله
داخل ليبيا هل يمكن ان نعتبر ليبيا الان
دوله ولا فعلا صارت اللا دوله بعد اللي
حصل بال 2011
ليبيا توجد فيها دوله صحيح هي بالحد
الادنى ولكن لا توجد فيها حكومه واحده ولا
توجد فيها حكومه حقيقيه الى حد الان لكن
كدوله ما زالت موجوده كدوله
يعني مؤسسات شرق مؤسسات غرب
الناس بتدفع هون وناس بتدفعه هون ولكن
الحقيقه الحقيقه انها تتعاون بالحد الادنى
وفي خطوات الان في خطوات يعني تبعناها
احنا في مصرف ليبيا المركزي هناك اجتماعات
عديده بين الشرق والغرب وايضا في المؤسسات
الاخرى مثلا ديوان المحاسبه
والرقابه الاداريه ايضا حيكون دورها جيد
وفعال الان بعد مجلس النواب عدل القانون
النفط والغاز امتى راح تصير تحط فلوسها
بالبنك المركزي
النفط والغاز النفط والغاز موحد الان صحيح
ان القرار قرار حكومه متاهه الولايه قرار
حكومه البيبه انه هو اصدر قرار وحول ازاح
مصطفى صنعال الاوزاب دكتور فرحات بن جداره
وكان هذا قرار خاطئ ويعني قرار باطل شرعيا
ولكن انا اتصلت بالسيد فرحات بن جداره
وقال لي حنتعامل مع المؤسسه هذه المؤسسه
الليبيين ولن يعني انحاز مع حكومه ضد
حكومه واحنا رحبنا لما اي مسؤول يقول
نتعامل مع المؤسسه ليبيا بما يخدم مصلحه
الليبيه وحنتعامل مع الكل رحبنا واعتقد هو
موجود
وماشيه خطوات المؤسسه النفط تحاول ان هي
تجعل الانتاج مستقر او ممكن حتى تزيد
الانتاج واعتقد انه فيها خطوات خطوات جيده
بغض النظر عن القرار يعتبر قرار غير
قانوني وغير شرعي
بدي ارجع معك لموضوع المصالحه المصالحه
ذكرت حضرتك انه مع 17 فبراير بعد القوه
اختلفت فيما بينها وانجزتوا كثير بهذا
المجال ماذا عن المصالحه مع اطياف النظام
السابق او مع الداعمين للنظام السابق
اوله هو بالنسبه للنظام السابق يعني
لابد ان نعترف انه هو يعني كل
حكومه ولكل
حقبه
يكون فيها نظام معين وهذا النظام اذا كان
مش ديمقراطي حينتهي طبعا ليه عمر معين وان
النظام السابق تاريخي انتهي ولكن يعني
يعني اقصد ان كل اعضاء النظام السابق
والا اللي كانوا في النظام السابق
الليبيين وهذين لهم حقوق وحقوقنا وحقوقهم
متساويه ما فيش فرق خلاص ننسى الان امامنا
وطن امامنا ليبيا فبراير نظام سابق اي
مسميات اخرى لابد ان نحن نعمل معا
وبالنسبه للمصالحه هي اساسا واقعيين بدات
المصالحه هذه كيف بدات وتقولين كيف بدات
صحيح ما فيش معتمر كبير تقوده الامم
المتحده ولا الاتحاد الافريقي ولا المجلس
الرئاسي وقاعدين يخططوه لحد الان لكن
المصالحه مع النظام السابق بدات من حكومه
السراج حكومه السراج فيها وزراء كانوا من
نظام السابق اللي الحاج محمد السياله
والدكتور طاهر الجيمي هذا مكانهم النظام
السابق ايضا الان نشوفوا حكومه دبيبه
حكومه دبيبه رئيسها من النظام السابق يعني
يوم من الايام كان مبعوث شخصي معمر
القذافي لمدينه مصراته على اساس انه
يتخلوا على الثوره وتعرض حتى
للحبس في مدينه مصراته يوم او يومين في
البدايه الثوره وبعد ان طلعها وعدى ارجع
ارجع وقعد يامن فيه الوقود يشتري في
الوقود لنا فهذا الرئيس الان من نظام
السابق محمد
وزير الاقتصاد محمد الحويج من نظام السابق
عديد الوزراء الاخرين هم من نظام السابق
يعني المصالحه واقعيه راهي بدات مع النظام
السابق والدليل على ذلك انهم الان ممكن
يتوقع يعني في حال لو استلمتم الحكومه
بشكل مطلق في ليبيا انه يصير في اي اجراء
بخصوص المساجين المهمين الحقيقه من النظام
السابق الموجودين في السجون من امثال عبد
الله السنوسي وعبد الله منصور وغيرهم
بالنسبه لي يعني بسبب الاسباب لا اريد ان
يبقى اي ليبي لاسباب سياسيه لان احنا
عانينا من فتره النظام السابق معمر في ناس
كثيرين سجنهم بسبب احداث سياسيه او موقف
سياسي لا نريد احد ان يبقى بسبب موقف
السياسي ان كان في النظام السابق او كان
في العهد الملكي
والمصالحه تتطلب ايضا ان احنا لابد ان
يكون فيه اعفاء عفو عام بما لا يتعارض مع
الحقوق اللي هي الحقوق الشخصيه فانا
بالنسبه لي انا ما عنديش مانع لكن على شرط
انه هو لا يتعارض مع الحقوق يعني مقفول حق
الشخص اذا كان بيقدم شكوى فيه لكن يحاسبوه
على انه كان في النظام السابق خلاص انتهت
الفتره هذه الان وليبيا ولابد ان احنا
نترك هذا للقضاء الحقيقي القضاء اللي بدون
ضغط المفروض يكون عادل يعني نتركه للقضاء
اللي هو تجربه حزب البعث كثير في العراق
مفروض انه تعلم منها الكثيرون مساله
الاشتثاث للحزب
دعني اسالك عن نقطه مهمه جدا حضرتك ذكرتها
ودولتك ذكرت اكثر من مره انه في تدخلات
كتير بليبيا هناك من يتدخل بالقوى الناعمه
مثل كثير من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي الحقيقه
وهناك من يتدخل بالقوه الخشنه نتحدث عن
روسيا عن تركيا عن غيرها هل روسيا تغير اي
شيء في موقفها بعد الحرب في اوكرانيا اثر
على وضعهم في ليبيا والله بالنسبه
لروسيا يعني لم نشاهد منها مواقف في
الالعاب ما يتم في مجلس الامن اليومين
الماضيات سمعنا طبعا بالتاكيد انها فيه
روسيا عندها قوه موجوده على الارض قوه
عسكريه تتمثل في الفاجنر لا تراك كذلك هم
موجودين على الارض وهذا كان تم باتفاقيه
وقعناها احنا في ذلك الوقت
اعتقد ان اللي جايبه اتفاقيه انه هو ما
فيش مشكله كبيره جدا انه هو ياخر لان
اتفاقيه فيها مكتوبه الاتفاقيات على بها
جيدا ان من حق اي طرف ان يطلب من الطرف
الاخر اللي هو الغاء الاتفاقيه او تجميد
الاتفاقيه في ظرف تقريبا زمني لمده شهر او
شهرين لكن اعتقد ان ان خروج انا هذا حسب
تحليل الشخصي ان خروج القوات هي فيها حتى
بدون حتى قوه اخرى مش روسيه روسيا وتركيا
حتى قوات اخرى من قوات مسلحه افريقيه
موجود لكن اعتقد ان القوه هذه كلها تخرج
من ليبيا بعد تكون في حكومه الشرعيه
الحكومه الشرعيه تكون
انتخاب الان حكومه الملك لا اعتقد دوله
يقول لن اتنازل عن المقعد الا لرئيس حكومه
منتخب الانتخابات ما صارت ب 24 ديسمبر ومش
الواقع انها تصير بالفتره القادمه لانه ما
في اتفاق يعني الحقيقه على عقد هذه
الانتخابات اول شيء مين اللي عم بعطلها
ومتى بتتوقع انه يصير في انتخابات فعلا في
ليبيا سواء رئاسيه او برلمانيه والله
بالنسبه لي شخصيا
انا يعني محسوب عليه
ودفعت فيها تم غالي سته من من عائلتي من
اجل ماذا من اجل الحكم الديمقراطي
والتداول السلمي على السلطه بينما دبيبه
نقول لك هذا رئيس الحكومه المتهيا غير
مقتنع بالحكم الديمقراطي وهو يضحك ضحك على
الناس وشفناه انتم
الانتخابات شماعه بيعلق
لانه هو هو يريد الاستمرار هو وعائلته
للابد هذا برنامجهم وهو لما يقول النبي
نبي نسلم من حكم انتخابي باعتبار انه يقعد
في السلطه ويقدم احد الاشخاص الاخرين من
عائلتها يتقدم الانتخابات لكن بالنسبه
للانتخابات نقول هي يعني مطلب مهم جدا
واحنا انا مستعد موجود في حكومه في
المنطقه الشرقيه والغربيه اننا نتعاون مع
الامم المتحده ونهيئوا الانتخابات هذا
مستعدين لي متى كانت الامم المتحده
والليبيين جاهزين ولابد من
طبعا في خطوات اللي هي للتعديل الدستوري
اللي عملوه ما زال سن القوانين واحنا
مستعدين للمستعدين للانتخابات وننتظروا
فيه هذا يوم السعد وهذا يوم المنى لما
ليبيا تنتخب رئيس لها وتنتخب برلمان جديد
هذا انه تضربوا فيه ونتمنوه في في اقرب
الايام مش لشهر 12 نتمنى
في شهر خمسه
لكن ما في تزمين يعني ما في زمن محدد لعقد
هذه الانتخابات حتى الان
ما زال هي خطه مازال
عليها السيد عبد الله بتلي غير موضحه
المعالم لحد الان غير واضحه ولم يعلن
عليها بشكل رسمي هو قال الخطاب بس ونحن
ننتظر الخطه الكامله ونتمنى ايضا من بعثه
الامم المتحده انها هي لا تقصي الاجسام زي
مجلس الدوله والبرلمان مجد دوله والبرلمان
صحيح اخذوا فتره طويله جدا في التوافق لكن
الان متوافقين وفي نسبه كبيره جدا من
التوافق فنتمنى الاجسام هذه تكون مساهمه
في العمليه القادمه الانتخابيه واذا كان
في اي برنامج اخر
شفاته الامم المتحده سواء توحيد المؤسسات
او
الاشراف على بعض المؤسسات ان يكون مجلس
الدوله والبرلمان دائما موجود لكن تجربه
تجربه اللجنه زي على غرار جنيف هذه
الليبيين راهوا عندهم في هاجس كبير
ومتخوفين منها على مزارات في ذلك الوقت
وكان هذا يعتبر زمان في ذلك الوقت لجرى
فيها يعتبر عند الليبيين ما زال فيه يعتبر
عيب وحسمه لكن الان زي ما يقول المثل يقول
الناس على دين ملوكهم بعد شفنا ان رئيس
الدوله يدعوا يستخدم في المال والرشوه
فراهو الوضع خطير جدا لو كان
نسال عنه ربما
ايوه ايوه الخروج من هذا
الانغلاق في الافق السياسيه يكون عن طريق
الانتخابات وربما تحدد لاحقا طالما فشلنا
باجراءها باربعه وعشرين ديسمبر شكرا جزيلا
لك السيد رئيس الحكومه الليبيه المكلفه من
مجلس النواب اللي بسيد فتحي باشاغه الف
شكر لك على المشاركه معنا شكرا
وبهذا مشاهدينا الكرام انتهت هذه المقابله
الخاصه مع رئيس الحكومه الليبيه المكلفه
من مجلس النواب فتحي بشاغ الى لقاء قريبا
مع مقابله جديده ودمتم بالف خير
[موسيقى]